this guy is a traitor a treasonous and
and he has broken every law of the
united states and i'm not for the death
penalty so if i'm not for the death
penalty want to do it illegally shoot
the son of a
date 2017
target julian assange
the founder of wikileaks
location the ecuadorian embassy in
london
objective killer capture origins of this
order from quote the highest levels end
quote of the us government and cia
normally a target like asajj would be
easy grab him from his way home from
work or shoot him as he walks to get his
morning coffee the only problem was
asajj did none of these things he hadn't
done any of those things in years
for five years julian assange had been
hiding in the ecuadorian embassy in
london killing him there or sending in
the police would go against
international law and be a foreign
relations disaster so the cia had to
concoct another plan
first they discussed secretly kidnapping
him from the embassy and bringing him
back to america but that would make it
too obvious america broke the law so
they changed tactics kidnap him turn him
over to the british that way no one
would know who was behind it then right
but then there was still the chance he
wouldn't get extradited back to the us
if the british police got him eventually
they got so desperate that they had no
choice they discussed the unthinkable
did the cia plot and plan to kill julian
assange
well unthinkable for everyone else very
thinkable for the cia going against
every international law they
contemplated assassinating julian
assange in the embassy where he lived
poisoned snipers sending in assassins
nothing was off the table but then came
another variable the u.s didn't plan for
the russians realizing the cia would
want to get rid of asajj they decided to
do the opposite they would help him
escape to mother russia after all the
russians didn't grant edward snowden
asylum out of the goodness of their
hearts but because it was a great way to
humiliate the us doing the same for
assaj would be another great victory the
cia finds out about the russians plans
so they scrapped their killer capture
plans and now have to brainstorm how
they would intercept a russian
extraction if the russians were going to
help him escape by car the cia would
crash into it with their own vehicle
then grabbing him while prepared for a
firefight in the process in the middle
of london if the russians were going to
fly him out they would get the british
police to shoot out the plane's wheels
before it could take off to moscow the
us uk and russian intelligences were in
a race to see who would get to julian
assange first quote it got to the point
where every human being in the three
block radius of the embassy in london
was working for one of the intelligence
services whether they were street
sweepers or police officers or security
guards end quotes the question is why
why was this one man so feared by the us
government that they were completely
detached from reality that they were
concocting plans to kidnap or
assassinate him within a foreign embassy
in a foreign country what does it take
to get to the top of the cia's hit list
i'm only asking for a friend
[Music]
of wikileaks
london police have arrested wikileaks
here you can see
being dragged out of the ecuadorian
even if you're not on a killer capture
list and you're not doing anything
illegal having all your browsing history
logged and linked to you by your
internet provider so it's available to
governments and hackers is probably not
a good idea that's where private
internet access comes in or pia private
internet access is the world's leading
no lock vpn provider a vpn or virtual
private network basically reroutes all
your internet traffic through vpn
servers all over the world this makes
sure your ip address is completely
hidden and it allows for some cool hacks
like watching jio restricted netflix
contents pia is ridiculously easy to use
has over 30 million downloads with 24 7
live customer supports and it's at an
extremely affordable price point it's
recommended in forbes pc magazine life
hacker and more and is today's video
sponsor here's how it works you sign up
and download the pia app on your phone
or laptop once you open up the app you
can switch your location to almost
anywhere in the world and boom you're
protected and you can access your
restricted content on streaming
platforms like netflix simply go to a
site like
unogs.com search for a movie you want
see what countries it's available in
connect to one of those countries in the
vpn hit refresh and there you go and for
a limited time private internet access
is giving you guys two years plus three
months free for just two dollars and
eight cents a month with a 30 day money
back guarantee so you have nothing to
lose so protect yourself by pausing the
video and clicking the link in the video
description below to claim this very
affordable offer right now
[Music]
julian assange was born in australia in
1971 and by just 16 years old he was
already a hacker under the codename
mendax asajj broke into some pretty huge
organizations what does the pentagon the
u.s department of defense nasa panasonic
and lockheed martin all have in common
they were all hacked by assaj when he
was just a teenager needless to say he
was a child prodigy the kind of person
you'd only expect to see in movies that
was until 1991 when asajj got caught
trying to hack into a canadian
telecommunications company at the age of
20.
he spent two years in jail and was
released in 1993 on good behavior after
agreeing to use his skills to help the
australian police from then on he led a
pretty quiet life he took some classes
at the university of melbourne and then
in 1999 he registers the domain
leaks.org but this domain will remain
unused for another 7 years until 2006
when he started the organization that
would make him one of the most feared
men by almost every global superpower
[Music]
wikileaks changed the game when it
launched in 2006 it was like nothing the
world had ever seen before anyone with
any important information or proof of
classified secrets could submit their
data to wikileaks anonymously something
that was not very common back then it
worked like a really big dropbox but
instead of sharing pictures from family
holidays you could share top secret
information with the publishers they
would sort through the info decide if it
was important enough to publish and then
they would pass it on to huge news
agencies like the guardian or the new
york times what made wikileaks different
from other whistleblower organizations
is that they could never really be
charged with stealing information they
didn't do any of the hacking themselves
so to a certain extent they were
innocent which led to one other major
advantage wikileaks had since they
weren't involved in stealing the
information the classified documents
they published could be used in courts
this was a game changer and terrifying
for powerful people with dark secrets to
hide because if the whistleblowers have
published the leaks themselves us law
will make it impossible to use that
illegally obtained evidence to prosecute
people or governments but because
wikileaks kept their hands cleaned the
data they published could be used in any
court in the us at first the group
didn't gain much recognition they leaked
the us handbook for the treatment of
prisoners at guantanamo bay in 2007 and
in 2009 they posted more than 500
thousand pages of messages sent on 911
but nothing quite caught the government
or the public's attention at least not
until 2010
in april 2010 wikileaks releases this
video it's a simple low quality video
from an apache helicopter involved in a
baghdad air strike on july 12 2007.
parts of the video unfortunately have to
be censored for the youtube algorithm
it's available uncensored if you want to
search for it yourself this video was an
airstrike that killed 18 people pretty
standard stuff in the us military what
was strange however was that for a group
of armed insurgents they seem to be
walking around rather calmly while a
loud heavily armed unmistakably western
apache helicopter was roaming above
but rest assured the us military
promised us that quote there is no
question that coalition forces were
clearly engaged in combat operations
against a hostile force
move along there's nothing to see here
but worders weren't happy with that
answer so they found a freedom of
information act to request a copy of a
video of the engagement but to no avail
that was until the encrypted footage
made its way to wikileaks they decrypted
it titled the video collateral murder
published it and this is what it
revealed
these were not enemy insurgents hostile
forces that the us military shot up but
two unarmed photographers for the news
agency worders namir noor aldine and his
driver saheed chama the pilots mistook
their cameras for weapons and a myriad
of other casualties that didn't have any
weapons or seem to be hostile at all the
us military just tried to cover up
friendly fire on journalists and almost
instantly the video was spread to every
newspaper and online publication around
the world of course our top story this
morning the white house blasting the
release of over 90 000 u.s military
records on the war in afghanistan
wikileaks.org a whistleblower website
has published what it says are nearly 92
000 official u.s documents of raw data
on the debts and casualties collected
over the past six years the wikileaks
website released nearly 400 000 secret
u.s files on the iraq war late today it
was the largest leak of classified u.s
files in history everyone came to know
the name wikileaks and julian assange
everyone including the us government and
they were not happy the pentagon called
wikileaks a national security threat the
person who leaked the video chelsea
manning got cut not because of wikileaks
she was arrested for leaking the video
and thousands of other classified
documents to the organization they tried
to block off wikileaks's funding but the
organization just moved to bitcoin but
at the end of the day they couldn't
arrest assad for publishing the video
since he had no involvement in stealing
it but just a few months after leaking
the most embarrassing clip against the
us government in recent memory julian
assange was accused of a crime a crime
that would conveniently discredit him
discredit wikileaks and discredit any
other lease they would publish in the
future
[Music]
in august 2010 julian assange visited
sweden to get support for wikileaks
after the collateral murder video he was
obviously not comfortable with what the
us would do as revenge and he hopes
sweden will offer him and wikileaks some
protection except three months later
swedish police issued an arrest warrant
for assad they accused him of sexually
assaulting two women on his visit to
sweden by the time the warrant came out
he was in the united kingdom even though
assad gave himself up to the british
police in december he still insisted
that he was innocent and he was released
on bail and he had his suspicions wasn't
it a little too convenient that just as
wikileaks rocked the world with the
collateral murder video swedish police
accused him of committing a crime that
would discredit his character his
organization and any information he
shared up to that point at least that's
what assad believed he spoke of sweden's
quote very very poor judicial system and
quote weakened by external political
meddling careerism and a culture of
quote crazed radical feminist ideology
end quote the only problem with this
argument was that swedish law prohibits
extraditions for political crimes
including espionage and for cases
eligible for the death penalty something
that assad was sure the us would work
around
with the cards stacked against them
julian assange knew that he would have
to act quickly to save himself from
getting extradited to sweden if he was
put in jail in his mind there was no
doubt the u.s would find a way to
extradite him back to the u.s for
whatever crimes they were charging with
soon and on may 30th 2012 the supreme
court ruled asajj would be extradited to
sweden to stand trial for the
accusations the only problem was no one
knew where assad was he'd been cut out
on bail for the whole trial but after
the supreme court ruling he seemed to
have disappeared into thin air he hadn't
left the country the british government
was short of that but where could he
have gone no one would find out until it
was too late at the moment he was at the
ecuadorian embassy in london negotiating
being given asylum by their governments
[Music]
[Applause]
on august 16 2012 the foreign minister
of ecuador announced that julian assange
had been given asylum at the ecuadorian
embassy in london
we trust that the united kingdom will
offer as soon as possible the guarantee
for the safe passage for this asylum of
mr assange and that they will respect
those international agreements that they
have signed in the past and that they
have always respected
a tiny office in the embassy was
converted into a studio with a bed
shower treadmill kitchenette and
computer if he had guests they'd visit
him in his little studio his lawyer's
therapist and even a personal trainer
had to make do with the small space
if he ever stepped foot outside the
embassy british police officers were
front and center ready to arrest him on
the spot for skipping bail and he would
stay trapped in the embassy for five
years before wikileaks released their
most damaging data dumped yet all at the
cost of the us government's dignity
[Music]
julian assange was a target for the us
government under both president obama
and president trump he embarrassed the
military show them how weak their
security was and on march 7 2017 he
released what they called vault 7
arguably the most embarrassing data leak
in the history of the cia and the us
governments what was involved 7 all the
internal documentation regarding the
cia's ultra secret hacking division and
its tactics the guys who were supposed
to be the best hackers in the world had
apparently been hacked this breach was
not just embarrassing it took away years
of agency pride and dignity the
organization tasked with keeping america
secrets couldn't even stop a leak of
their most classified information vault
7 had it all details on electronic
surveillance equipment cyber warfare
weapons and how they could break into
almost every cell phone operating system
on the planets all out in the open for
the world to see agency officials used
to quote laugh about wikileaks end
quotes mocking the state department and
the pentagon for allowing so much
material to escape their control but now
it was their turn and for the cia
revenge wasn't even a question it was
the only answer their blood was boiling
and all they could see was red an
example had to be made in the main
targets of course it was julian assange
[Music]
[Applause]
on april 13 2017 the cia director at the
time mike pompeo was on a war path less
than five weeks after vault 7's
publication director pompeo made his new
stance very clear wikileaks was now a
full-blown non-state hostile
intelligence service and a direct enemy
of the united states
wikileaks walks like a hostile
intelligence service and talks like a
hostile intelligence service and has
encouraged its followers to find jobs at
the cia in order to obtain intelligence
it's time to call out wikileaks for what
it really is
a non-state hostile intelligence service
often abetted by state actors like
russia
this new classification was bureaucratic
speak that now justified the use of
offensive measures against this
non-state hostile intelligence service
the fight was on and according to mike
pompeo there were no rules after his
speech he gave cia officers the order to
figure out the quote art of the possible
end quote he said quote nothing's off
limits don't self-censor yourself i need
operational ideas from you i'll worry
about the lawyers in washington end
quote which led to all the insane plans
we talked about at the start of this
video despite all the planning though
their plans never went forward because
their lawyers said it would be a bad
idea and it wasn't because they thought
let's not kill a guy who hasn't even
been proven guilty of the crime no they
didn't do it because the lawyers in
washington said it wasn't a good idea so
even though assad escaped becoming the
next name scratch off the cia's hit list
life wasn't going so well for him at the
same time either
[Music]
[Applause]
spending more than 6 years as a guest in
someone's house seems like a bit much so
it wasn't totally surprising when that
ecuadorians finally started getting
tired of a sergeant 2018 apparently he
refused to clean up after his cat michi
also known as the embassy cat and
started getting on the nerves of the
ecuadorian government by posting
damaging information about the new
ecuadorian president lenin mourinho on
wikileaks at least you can't say
wikileaks is biased exposing your hosts
and leaving your cat's poop all over the
place doesn't seem like the best way to
stay in someone's good graces so in july
2018 president moreno said he wanted
asajj out as soon as it was safe for him
to leave in october that same year assaj
tried suing the ecuadorian government
for cutting his internet access and
threatening to turn him over to the uk
police pretty odd and things only went
downhill from there it turns out that uc
global the company the embassy paid to
keep assad safe had been spying on him
for u.s intelligence all along the same
company that embassy paid more than 5
million to over the last 7 years assaj
had become more trouble than he was
worth and the embassy was about to cut
him off
[Music]
on april 2nd 2019 president lenin moreno
announced asajj was no longer welcome at
the embassy the reason it had everything
to do with asajj violating the terms of
his asylum and had nothing to do with
the fact that wikileaks had published
pictures that linked moreno to a
corruption scandal asajj had very little
time to prepare when nine days later the
ecuadorian government invited british
police into the embassy to arrest asajj
on the basis of skipping bail that very
same day asajj was found guilty and
sentenced 50 weeks in prison starting
may 1st
the us's time had come asajj had been
secretly indicted over a year earlier in
march 2018 and on the same day he was
arrested in london the indictment was
unsealed he was charged with conspiracy
to commit computer intrusion a month
later while serving his sentence in the
bellmarsh prison the u.s added 17
charges to the list the maximum sentence
a hundred and seventy years in prison a
hundred and seventy years for the leader
of an organization that wasn't all that
different from other news agencies that
published leaks at his extradition
hearing in may 2019 asajj said quote i
do not wish to surrender myself for
extradition for doing journalism that
has won many many awards and protected
many people end quote
on july 4th 2021 a judge denied that
extradition request on the basis of
assad's mental health making him a
suicide risk but he was also denied bail
because he's a flight risk so for now
asajj hangs in limbo
julian assange is currently still in
belmar's prison at the time of recording
this video if he's extradited he faces
solitary confinement in a super max
prison a hundred and seventy years in
prison for someone who did the same job
as most journalists out there where i
wouldn't be surprised if he met the same
fate as our friend whose first name
starts with a j and last name starts
with an e time will tell what the future
holds for the whistleblower pioneer
for humiliating both our elected leaders
and the media class julian assange's
life has been destroyed what i think
he's done is spoken truth to power that
should not be a basis on which you end
up in prison ultimately he should come
back to this country to face trial
i think he should be punished
when china
demands the extradition of a canadian
journalist
what happens when saudi arabia does the
same thing about someone living in
argentina
we are setting a precedent right now
that we are going to live with
for the next hundred years
if you are new here we make video essays
documentaries just like this one every
single week on the most provocative
stuff in the world of money power war
and crime so if you like this one you're
definitely gonna like the other one so
click that red subscribe button below
and if you want more day in the life
kind of stuff you can follow me on
instagram at jaketrend.io thanks for
being part of the watch of the end club
keep sharpening that mind stay dangerous
out there and i will see you guys in the
next one
[Music]
you